madame monsieur bonsoir un important feu
de garrigue mena ce soir le village de
rodez dans les pyrénées-orientales
une partie des habitants a dû être
évacué 600 hectares ont déjà été
détruits sept canadair et un trackair
sont venus renforcer les effectifs au
sol avec deux jours d'avancé sur le
calendrier officiel c'est déjà la
rentrée pour les écoliers de haute saône
qui pratiquent la semaine des quatre
jours nous verrons si cette formule est
adaptée aux rythmes de l'enfant la
chaussure française de luxe victime de
la concurrence chinoise
rien qu'aujourd'hui on a appris la
liquidation judiciaire de stéphane
kélian production et le dépôt de bilan
de charles jourdan en visant le secteur
a perdu deux tiers de ses effectifs
des pluies diluviennes frappent
l'autriche et la suisse des coulées de
boue ont causé la mort de quatre
personnes dans ces deux pays
polémique autour du dernier logiciel
créé par google le moteur de recherche
américain sur internet
il propose des images satellites de tous
les lieux de la planète des images qui
inquiètent elles pourraient être
détournés par des terroristes après un
mois de juillet très morose la
fréquentation touristique s'annonce
meilleur au mois d'août paris et le sud
de la france team larressingle du jeu le
littoral breton connaît une saison
plutôt difficile
le vent très fort qui souffle ce soir
dans les pyrénées-orientales compliquer
la tâche des sapeurs pompiers qui
luttent contre un incendie de garric
très important sept canadair et un
tracker restent mobilisés jusqu'à la
nuit tombée 600 hectares ont déjà été
détruits le village de rodez a dû être
partiellement évacuée sur place frelick
monteil frais d'agban
ce soir quatre cent cinquante pompiers
tentent de maîtriser un feu
incontrôlable attisés par des vents
soufflant jusqu'à 130 kilomètres heure
l'incendié menace le massif des astres
dans les pyrénées-orientales
cet après midi les flammes se sont
approchées à quelques dizaines de mètres
des 700 habitants de la commune de rodez
désolation c'est vraiment la désolation
parce que tout était vert quand même bon
sexe et la garrigue mais bon c'est quand
même relativement vercors si ses traits
à ses berceuses voile et là c'est
vraiment un faux quality ce soir 600
hectares de garrigue ravagé mais aucun
blessé
aucune maison détruite à rodez une
cinquantaine d'habitants sont évacuées
dans l'urgence et on va essayer de rodez
depuis 15 heures les pompiers de
l'hérault de l'aude et des
pyrénées-orientales ont mobilisé les
grands moyens canadair tracker
hélicoptère
le risque pour nous c'est que ça
s'engage dans le massif des alpes où on
a des milliers d'hectares menacée donc
là on a actuellement sept canadair qui
font transit sur nous plus le dash + 2
ou 4 trackair et au niveau des moyens au
sol on a environ 400 sapeurs-pompiers
qui sont mobilisés en fin d'après-midi
la nationale 116 et une ligne de chemin
de fer ont été coupées les forces de
l'ordre ont commencé à évacuer une
deuxième commune bouleternère dans le
massif des astres au portugal cette fois
la situation est toujours très
préoccupante 21 feux sont hors de
contrôle
la france a dépêché aujourd'hui deux
canadair et les 2000 pompiers attendent
maintenant des renforts aériens
allemands néerlandais et italien romain
clément partez partez partez
pourquoi rester l'aparté le brasier
continue sa progression
tôt ce matin la ville de coimbra et ses
cent sept mille habitants étaient cernés
par les flammes
impuissante ces femmes assistent à la
destruction de leur maison dans la nuit
dix autres habitations vont subir le
même sort
et même avec les meilleures volontés la
population est condamné à fuir
dieu aidez nous il n'y a aucune pression
dans les tuyaux
la situation reste critique sur
l'ensemble du territoire
plusieurs autoroutes sont menacés et le
pire est peut-être à venir les
températures sont annoncées à la hausse
jusqu'à mercredi
ce soir 21 foyers restent hors de
contrôle
16 des 18 régions que compte le pays
sont toujours en état d' alerte après le
premier ministre hier le président
portugais appel à la mobilisation
nationale
je demande à toutes les entreprises
portugaises de libérer immédiatement
leurs employés pompiers volontaires on a
impérativement besoin de sur le terrain
les 3000 portugais mobiliser combat
désormais aux côtés deux renforts
européen après la france et l'espagne
aujourd'hui l'allemagne et l'italie
doivent dès demain envoyé des moyens
aériens et humains
depuis le début de l'été ces incendies
dont beaucoup seraient d'origine
criminelle ont coûté la vie à 14
personnes au total 135 mille hectares
sont partis en fumée
cette journée de lundi a marqué la fin
des vacances pour les écoliers de haute
saône après avec 12 jours d'avancé sur
la calendrier officiel
ils ont donc repris le chemin de l'école
c'est presque une tradition depuis huit
ans maintenant dans ce département qui
pratique la semaine de quatre jours anne
guéri marque de langenhagen croisés la
directrice a une astuce la bonne vieille
méthode coué quelques jeux demain does
it war in et le tour est joué
l'art ancien 22 août cette finale
mad men une seule larme et pourtant un
quart d'heure plus tôt ce n'était pas
gagné
le temps les parents avec eux le coeur
serré moi tout seul à la maison
un vase y est vous vous êtes commandes
dans fou tu veux nous mêmes mais une
fois à l'intérieur la directrice rassure
tour à tour les parents les petits
et ça marche vous avez le droit de jouer
un peu mieux et attendent le moment
propice pour elle et où maman monde
attend volant elle est partie sur boulot
mes cahiers et toi tu vas faire quoi
pendant ce temps les grands du village
règne car pour l'école primaire du bourg
voisin à 5 km de là
et eux à l'évidence digère moins bien la
rentrée scolaire à la longue où tu te
rends compte que les autres naïvement
ils sont encore en vacances ça fait
bizarre
les en contrepartie la semaine scolaire
n'est que de quatre jours tous les
week-ends sont libres pour des raisons
différentes les parents comme les
enseignants adore c'est pas mal d'avoir
donné samedi matin c'est des fois il
faut se déranger ouais pour la gauche ce
samedi c'est pas mal je pense que le
fait d'avoir un petit peu moins de
vacances fait qu' ils ont peut être un
petit peu moins de pertes au niveau des
hacker qu'ils avaient au mois de juin
chaque année dans les deux villages
dosso et de brugnons la rentrée scolaire
anticiper et évaluer et soumise au vote
des parents elle n'est maintenu qu'à
cette condition obtenir l'adhésion de
tous en france 6 millions de jeunes sont
scolarisés en maternelle et dans le
primaire la rentrée anticipée concerne
deux millions d'enfants qui pratiquent
la semaine des quatre jours
c'est donc on l'a dit la haute saône qui
a donné le coup d'envoi aujourd'hui pour
les autres le calendrier s'échelonnent
jusqu'à la rentrée officielle ce sera le
2 septembre prochain
cette formule de la semaine de 4 jours
est elle adaptée aux enfants aujourd'hui
gilles de robien
le ministre de l'éducation nationale a
affirmé qu'il ne voulait pas généraliser
ce système qui est loin de faire
l'unanimité
josé blanc la pierre alexandra renard en
attendant la rentrée ces petits
parisiens s'occupent comme ils peuvent
certains commencent même à trouver le
temps long
mais nizar devront encore attendre
jusqu'au 2 septembre
car pas de semaine de quatre jours à
paris où un débat de plusieurs mois sur
la question n'a pas réussi à mettre tout
le monde d'accord
ce qu'il ya tellement de gens se séparer
légalement mariés
enfin
sont restés deux heures demain matin
donc les pères ou des mères
maj deux jours entiers avec la rentrée
on a encore besoin de quelque chose de
très régulier comprennent pas si le jour
il ya plus qu les repas on revient
dessus très très bien avoir toute la
semaine pendant les cinq jours
quelques parents ce qui coince donc
c'est le samedi côté enseignants ce
serait plutôt le mercredi sans compter
la pression des rendez vous du caté ou
de la piscine
finalement seuls les experts semblent
s'accorder pour condamner la semaine de
quatre jours ça va à l'encontre des
besoins et des intérêts des enfants
surtout des plus défavorisés j'entends
les enfants dont la famille cumule les
discuter matérielle morale sociale etc
pourtant aujourd'hui même des grandes
villes comme lyon ou bordeaux sont
conquises est pas prête de renoncer à la
formule allégée
finalement chaque commune fait comme
elle veut pourvu que les 936 heures
obligatoires soient bouclés dans l'année
ce qui donne 30 2 % d'élèves soumis aux
quatre jours 17% à 4 jours et demi avec
le mercredi matin
51% avec le samedi matin pas de
consignes du côté des pouvoirs publics
le ministre gilles de robien déclaré ce
matin que ce serait à l'école tu es
décidé en tout cas semaine de quatre
jours ou pas le coût de la rentrée le
même pour tout le monde entre les
fournitures les transports et les frais
divers
les familles débourseront quasiment
autant que l'an dernier de 45 à 800
euros en fonction de l'âge des enfants
séverine lebrun bernie mériaux alors
c'est moins cher ayant la puce moi je
prends le moins cher et il ya un maître
tous les arguments sont bons pour
convaincre
maïlys rend ton quatrième cette année et
dont les rayons de cet hypermarché tout
lui plaît le problème c'est que la
famille est grande trois enfants alors
l'objectif c'est de limiter les dépenses
minimum 400 euros tout en pensant que en
tout le mois de septembre les
professeurs vorachit qu'un truc un autre
le budget de l'écolier stable -0 44% par
rapport à l'année dernière avec un grand
écart selon la classe un peu plus de 122
euros pour le cp 329 en 6e 590 en
seconde générale jusque 772 euros en
seconde technologie industrielle
dès l'entrée au collège l'allocation de
rentrée scolaire 263 euros 28 ne suffit
plus ce qui n'arrange pas les affaires
de notre famille
ils sont plus en plus grande dans les
cartables sont plus en plus
euh dépenseront finalement 110 euros
pour la plus grande mais reste encore
l'épreuve de force avec les deux plus
petits qui n'ont pas encore reçu leurs
listes de fournitures scolaires
rafales de mauvaises nouvelles dans
l'industrie de la chaussure française de
luxe liquidation judiciaire pour
stéphane kélian production dépôt de
bilan pour charles jourdan
en dix ans le secteur a perdu deux tiers
de ses effectifs
il est touché de plein fouet par la
mondialisation didier guyot martin topi
évidemment envie de demander la
liquidation
le couperet est tombé ce matin
le chausseur de luxe stéphane kélian met
la clé sous la porte 143 personnes se
retrouvent au chômage
le directeur général est là il est pris
à partie par des salariés que c'est un
groupe de financiers belge qui avait
racheté la marque il ya trois ans de
cela des financiers qui une fois l'usiné
ferme s en iront produire ailleurs en
chine ou en inde
et tant pis pour les ouvriers latéraux
pris par le goodwill ils veulent pas
faire produire enfin c'est le flou ce
qui les intéresse est en fait c'est le
monsieur à l'opération financière qui
l'a fait en achetant les magasins
relâchant la balle a marqué bien triste
coïncidence le groupe charles jourdan
annonce ce soir qu'il dépose le bilan
ce sont cette fois-ci 432 salariés qui
sont menacés et rare de
commercialisation concurrence coûts de
fabrication élevés la production
française est moribond on a dès 2003
attirer l'attention d'un à l'époque de
malades quand elle était ministre de
l'industrie j'ai bien vu lumière de
spécifique donc je crois que le sort la
sueur est scellé depuis déjà pas mal de
temps et on laisse mourir les sociétés
sans essayer de trouver des solutions
pas trop si reina
c'est un coup dur pour la ville de
romans où les magasins du deal sont
encore nombreux les clients affluent
mais pour combien de temps encore après
guéri s'il y avait près de 300
fabricants
aujourd'hui deux sociétés de luxe existe
avec près de 20% de chômeurs son titre
de capitale de la chaussure ne
correspond plus à la réalité
un appel à témoins a été lancé après
l'accident mortel qui a coûté la vie
hier soir à paris à deux personnes
fauchées par une voiture à la terrasse
d'un café sur les grands boulevards
les deux conducteurs qui ont provoqué
l'accident sont en garde à vue les deux
victimes sont une petite fille et sa
maman benoît bringer pascal caron la
voiture a fini sa course contre la
façade de cette brasserie des grands
boulevards parisiens
il était environ 20h30 hier soit dans
son embardée le véhicule fauche 4 passes
en une famille de sri lankais qui se
trouvait sur le trottoir à quelques
mètres les clients de la brasserie
terrifié par cet accident
justement nous la voiture est rentrée
dedans on est sorti on appelle les
pompiers
et puis on a aidé les gens à s'aider
encastré il ya des gens qui ont poussé
la voiture pour dix ans qu'est ce que
les gens quittent ensuite le conducteur
de la mercedes est sorti il a fini par
terre il pleurait c'est une petite fille
de 3 ans et sa mère sont grièvement
blessés elle meurt quelques heures plus
tard après avoir été conduite à
l'hôpital
à quelques mètres de la brasserie les
enquêteurs s'intéressent à une autre
voiture une opel elle aussi impliquée
dans l'accident selon les premières
constatations la première voiture une
mercedes noire aurait tourné au dernier
moment pour s'engager dans une rue sur
la gauche l'opel arrivant par derrière
la percute et la projette sur le
trottoir
une hypothèse que semble confirmer le
père de la famille pakistanaise
il a été entendu cet après midi par les
enquêteurs
lui n'a été que légèrement blessé mais
il a perdu sa fille et sa femme une
voiture en a percuté une autre qui se
trouvaient devant explique-t-il elle
nous est rentrée dedans
ma fille a été projeté mon épouse s'est
retrouvé sous la voiture
elle n'a pas survécu les conducteurs des
deux voitures sont ce soir toujours en
garde à vue
un dépistage aurait révélé des traces de
cocaïne sur l'un d'entre eux celui de la
deuxième voiture mais personne ne sait
pour l'instant si cette prise de cocaïne
étaient récentes ou pas est un appel à
témoins donc été lancée si vous avez
assisté à cet accident vous pouvez
appeler le 01 44 08 62 70 et dans le
même temps la préfecture de police de
paris communique ce chiffre du 1er
janvier au 15 août le nombre d'accidents
corporels a connu une légère baisse de
1% dans la capitale après demain
quarante mille personnes sont attendues
au stade dillon en martinique pour
assister à l'hommage national en
présence de jacques chirac tout lille
bien sûr est uni autour des familles des
152 victimes de l'accident d'avion la
semaine dernière au venezuela
certains proches ont la lourde tâche de
raconter ce qu'ils ont vu ces derniers
jours en se rendant à la chapelle
ardente de maracaibo anouk burel billets
dab
ici les nuits sont plus longues que les
jours depuis mardi ils veillent elodie
19 ans et sa mère mariannick sont mortes
dans l'accident
c'était leur seule leur nièce leur amie
la rose marie a été les yeux et les
oreilles de la famille à maracaibo au
venezuela
aujourd'hui elle raconte je ne voulais
peut-être pas leur une de manière s'il
s'écroule cassoulet les décors déjà en
fait c'est un idiot a pratiquement de la
chantilly vous n'avez pas envie de leur
faire mal et de leur dire que ces
personnes qu'on avait eues mais il y
avait du talent ça moi je m'y attendais
oui ok je savais que je n'allais pas
droit master
21 en fait moi moi je m'y attendais pas
les fêtes et masse hier soir venu elle
nous a donné les bonnes informations moi
je m'attendais vraiment pas à ce que ce
soit dans un état pareil la famille
commence à faire son deuil nuit après
nuit mais sans pouvoir matérialiser
vraiment la disparition des leurs on
veut que le gouvernement vénézuélien en
tout cas que le gouvernement français et
le gouvernement vénézuéliens s'arrange
pour que les corps soient rapatriés le
plus tôt possible
on ne veut plus attendre et dans ma
famille il ya des personnes qui vont
vraisemblablement crack est devenue
folle même peut-être je disais devenue
folle s'il faut attendre deux semaines
alors on pourra pas tant mieux - me du
moins ils font la douleur a laissé place
à la colère
car les familles ont besoin d'organiser
des obsèques dignes au plus bien sûr
toutes ces familles veulent connaître la
vérité sur les circonstances de ce crash
mais pour l'instant seule une
cinquantaine de familles s'est déjà
constituée partie civile
tout à l'heure le procureur chargé du
dossier s'est exprimé au micro de sa
masse ou là et de guillaume fautrat il a
expliqué qu'il y avait une bonne
coopération entre les autorités
françaises et vénézuéliennes elles
veulent savoir comment pourquoi leurs
maris fils et frère sont morts dans le
crash établir les responsabilités comme
une cinquantaine de familles endeuillées
ces femmes se sont constituées parties
civiles
je veux savoir comment ça s'est passé et
pour quelles raisons à voir à combien de
mètres à quelques mètres près les
projets ne sais pas je voudrais pas voir
ce sont ces plaintes qui ont permis au
procureur de fort de france d'ouvrir une
information judiciaire pour homicide
involontaire
les deux juges d'instruction qui l'a
mandaté sur place n'ont pas la main sur
l' enquête
ils doivent travailler en étroite
collaboration avec les enquêteurs
vénézuélien les dividendes qu'elles sont
liées au fait que tout s'est passé au
venezuela
les 116 investigations sur venezuela et
d'autres investigations d'autres
recherches auront lieu à paname
en colombie dont par conséquent en du
territoire français donc ceci exige une
excellente collaboration avec des
autorités étrangères concernées
notamment vénézuélienne et là j'ai eu de
bonnes garanties comme quoi la
coopération finalement on pourra se
faire sans difficulté aucune
les quatre procureurs vénézuélien
chargée de l'enquêté
ce prêt dont accepté prochainement que
les deux boîtes noires soit examiné en
france dans cette affaire
une autre bataille se dessine celle des
avocats maître germany saisi par une
dizaine de familles de victimes
dénoncent l'entrée dans le dossier de
ténor du barreau de la métropole et le
démarchage fait par des avocats
étrangers des vautours dit il il y
actuellement toute une série d'avocats
étrangers américains finissent junior
mexicain qui tente de rentrer par
effraction dans ce dossier se prétendant
saisie par des familles qui ne les
connaissent pas mais pour toutes les
familles de victimes
la première bataille à gagner c'est
celle du rapatriement des corps de leurs
proches c'est la priorité
depuis la série noire qui touche le
trafic aérien chaque jour apporte son
lot de révélations sur les lacunes en
matière de sécurité
aujourd'hui c'est le patron de
l'aviation civile qui révèle l'existence
d'une liste noire de pays
négligeant une liste tenue secrète pour
des raisons diplomatiques nicolas
lemarignier thierry breton 6 août 2005
un avion de la tunise air s'écrase en
méditerranée bilan 13 morts 14 août
un boeing de la compagnie est liée aux
s'écrase faisant 120 tu es une victime
deux jours plus tard 6e md 82 de la
compagnie west caribbean qui se crashe
tuant 160 personnes dont 152 français
une série noire qui pose la question des
contrôles de sécurité des différents
états auprès de leurs propres compagnies
dans le monde d'aujourd'hui le directeur
de l'aviation civile révèle l'existence
d'une liste de 30 pays dont les
contrôles sont insuffisants
une liste officieuse car officiellement
cette liste n'existe pas il faudrait
quand la face on a suffisamment
d'informations pour la faire mais encore
faut-il en avoir la volonté politique et
puis bien sûr il faut faire des normes
qui soit beaucoup plus sévère que celle
qui lie actuellement tant au niveau
oici c'est à dire au niveau
international qu'au niveau européen et
surtout les faire appliquer il faut de
la transparence
en attendant les bons élèves disposent
de moyens limités pour éviter les
catastrophes
chaque pays peut sur son territoire
organiser des contrôles surprises comme
celui ci les inspecteurs vérifient 53
points de contrôle en 45 minutes
bref un examen plus administratif que
technique doit s'adapter au temps
disponible en escale donc dans ce laps
de temps on essaie de caser à contrôler
ses carlingue parquet dans le désert
américain sont bonnes pour la casse
et pourtant c'est là que certaines
compagnies à bas prix viennent acheter
leurs avions pas étonnant alors que les
experts prédisent si rien n'est fait une
catastrophe aérienne par semaine en 2020
un ancien joueur du psg d'or ce soir en
prison godwin okpara est mise en examen
pour avoir abusé une jeune fille
originaire du nigeria qui vivaient sous
son toit
les faits se seraient déroulés dans sa
maison en région parisienne
pour l'instant le footballeur nie tout
en bloc et manuel lambert patrice
progert lebas villon et cossu pourtant
tina a dormi dans un sous sol sur un
matelas crasseux pendant 4 ans adoptée à
l'âge de 13 ans par godwin okpara ancien
joueur du psg international nigérian la
jeune fille pensait vivre un rêve
très vite elle devient bonne à tout
faire et souffre douleur de la famille
c'était inquiétant parce qu'on percevait
un certain degré de violence
dans les coûts dans les échanges de
paroles même s'il parlait dans leur
langue le 14 août dernier la jeune fille
aujourd'hui âgée de 17 ans s'enfuit en
pleurs dans les rues de chatou dans les
yvelines un facteur lui aurait alors
conseillé de porter plainte au
commissariat le plus proche
le footballeur professionnel or et à de
nombreuses reprises violé et torturé
l'adolescente avec la complicité de sa
femme et de sa belle mère
jeudi dernier les trois personnes ont
été interpellées et écroué pour viol
viol avec torture et barbarie
lors de sa garde à vue godwin okpara a
nié les faits selon lui la jeune nina
était consentante
l' enquête a été confiée à la brigade
des mineurs de saint germain en laye le
géant pharmaceutique merck n'en a pas
fini avec la justice vendredi dernier un
jury texan a condamné le laboratoire à
verser une grosse somme d'argent à la
veuve d'un homme qui avait pris
l'anti-inflammatoire vioxx
cette condamnation pourrait entraîner
bien d'autres poursuites à travers le
monde
en france les victimes de ce médicament
au controversé parle de premier pas
encourageant sophie rodier patrick
desmulie andré benoit 75 ans décédée
d'une hémorragie cérébrale en 2003 à
l'époque elle était traitée depuis trois
mois pour ses rhumatismes avec du vioxx
un anti inflammatoire soupçonné
aujourd'hui d'avoir tué 27 mille
personnes dans le monde son fils en est
certain c'est ce médicament du
laboratoire merck qui a provoqué sa mort
le 13 décembre malheureusement ma mère a
fait une chute donc nue sur le sur le
coup on a cru qu'elle était tombée
et puis je vois là une commotion
cérébrale point la ligne peu de temps
après on appellerait télévision que les
personnes qui prenaient du vioxx mesquer
d'avoir ce genre d'accident en décembre
dernier il décide donc de porter plainte
mais le procureur de lille ne donne pas
suite
depuis vendredi il a un nouvel espoir
d'obtenir gain de cause aux états unis
après six semaines de procès un tribunal
du texas a condamné le laboratoire à
verser une indemnité de 253 millions de
dollars à la veuve d'un utilisateur du
vioxx en france une centaine de victimes
présumées
regroupés en associations pourraient se
joindre aux actions collectives
américaine
aux etats unis c'est beaucoup plus
rapide déjà et puis il ya ces
regroupements possible de victimes qui
permettent des arrangements un mauvais
arrangement vaut mieux qu'un bon procès
et j'espère que les victimes françaises
vont pouvoir en bénéficier
en france les autorités sanitaires ont
recensé 550 accident grave liée au vioxx
dont une douzaine de décès le médicament
a été retiré du marché mondial
en 2004 la libération de notre confrère
de france 3 - est droitier avait été
enlevé il ya huit jours par des hommes
armés à gaza lors d'une conférence de
presse il a affirmé qu'ils avaient été
bien traités
pour l'instant aucune indication sur le
profil de serre à 21h52 ou ati doit
regagner la france demain christian ton
livre est en bonne santé
mohamed touati peut enfin rassurer ses
proches et leur dire son soulagement
il fut libéré boucher très heureux
d'être heureux d'être là pour voir
advenir le jour il ne nous dira que
quelques mots sur son enlèvement
changer de voiture et jusqu'au lieu de
détention
c'est très c'est une grande ferme peine
qu'un jeu fera pendant toute mon
attention
libéré en début d'après midi mohamed
touati a aussitôt tenu à remercier les
autorités palestiniennes au cours d'une
conférence de presse sur les
circonstances de sa libération
les services de sécurité palestiniens
n'ont fait aucun commentaire
alors à ça j'ai toujours aucune idée en
fait des gens qui ont détenu mohamed
c'est que je sais qu'il n'a pas changé
de mains je sais qu'il est resté un seul
endroit
il y a huit jours le technicien français
avait été enlevé près de son hôtel
trois hommes en armes à visage découvert
ils avaient embarqué dans un véhicule
et depuis plus aucune nouvelle ni
revendications de ses ravisseurs en
france comme à gaza
les appels s'étaient alors multipliées
pour demander sa libération
cet après midi le gouvernement français
s'est réjoui de ce dénouement
il a sa propre explication sur ce rapt
il semble qu'il s'agissait d'un
différend palestiniens dont nous ne
connaissons pas tous les éléments pour
sa famille à nanterre c'est le
soulagement et la joie tout l'après midi
on s'est pressé au domicile de la soeur
de mohamed touati le preneur de son de
france 3 sera de retour en france demain
ce soir les vingt-et-une colonies de la
bande de gaza sont vidés de leurs
habitants les dernières difficultés
devraient donc venir de cisjordanie où
deux colonies reste encore à évacuer ce
sera pour demain
en tout cas pour l'instant les forces
israéliennes se disent soulagés
l'évacuation de gaza n'aura pris que 7
jours une opération bien préparés sous
les yeux des journalistes du monde
entier charles enderlin alain grego l'ex
à rim s'est rendu sans encombre
enclavée en plein centre de la bande de
gaza c'était une des colonies les plus
religieux là encore les colons ont
présenté aux caméras une émotion une
douleur très réel c'est l'image que le
mouvement des implantations veut faire
passer dans l'opinion publique des juifs
religieux expulsés sans raison de leur
foyer pire de leur si nadal en face
l'armée avait préparé sa
contre-offensive soignants même
l'uniforme des soldats mais surtout une
transparence jamais vu attal l'opération
diffuser de bout en bout en direct sur
des chaînes israéliennes et étrangères
des autobus conduisait quotidiennement
la presse à pied d'oeuvre pour montrer
militaires et policiers évacuent ans
avec une compassion tout aussi réelle
des colons effondré
ce bras de fer médiatique les colons ont
perdu des points
le public n'a pas apprécié les insultes
contre les soldats et la violence contre
les policiers
et pendant une après l'autre leurs
anciennes maisons sont détruites
les colons de gaza se lance dans leur
nouvelle bataille à quelques km du
barrage des rays les ancrer ce qu'ils
appellent un camp de réfugiés une
manière de faire pression sur le
gouvernement
la puissance des pleurs des simples juif
est aujourd'hui telles que sharon ne
sera pas réélu qu pour l'heure en tout
cas le premier ministre dispose d'une
solide majorité parlementaire
des pluies diluviennes frappent
actuellement nos voisins suisses et
autrichiens deux personnes sont mortes
en autriche en suisse deux sapeurs
pompiers ont perdu la vie dans un
glissement terrain jean françois feer
est des torrents d'eau boueuse dans leur
course folle
ce matin les pluies diluviennes qui
s'abattent sur la suisse depuis trois
jours ont cessé pendant quelques heures
insuffisant pour faire rentrer les
rivières dans le relier à berne la
capitale on ne se déplace plus qu'en
barque
par endroits l'eau est montée jusqu'à 1
m la nuit dernière dans le canton de
lucerne deux pompiers sont morts
emportés par la boue ils tentaient
d'ériger un barrage de fortune
la circulation est impossible
l'électricité est coupée
plus d'un millier de personnes ont été
évacuées en autriche aussi la plus à
tuer à gaz n dans le sud du pays
une coulée de boue a détruit cette
maison en quelques secondes
ses deux occupants de 50 et de 77 ans
n'ont pas survécu
un voisin raconte la scène j'étais
dehors avec mon père dit il la boue a
foncé sur nous et nous avons pu en
sortir vivants mais j'ai eu la peur de
ma vie
100 litres d'eau par mètre carré
du jamais vu en 60 ans dans cette partie
du pays et c'est pareil depuis le début
de l'été en roumanie en bulgarie
les intempéries ont fait plus de 40
victimes et la pluie devrait redoubler
dans les prochains jours
les autorités allemandes viennent de
lever en partie le mystère autour de
celui qu'on appelle piano man en mai
dernier l'image de cet homme dépeint
comme un pianiste virtuose et amnésique
avait fait le tour du monde
aujourd'hui on apprend qu'il est
originaire de bavière et que ses talents
musicaux sont loin d'être évidents
laurent bouvier sur les photos il a
l'air triste doux et inoffensif un grand
jeune homme aux cheveux clairs découvert
par la police le 7 avril dernier
errant sur cette plage du kent sans
papiers est vêtu d'un costume trempé
dont les étiquettes été arrachées
mystère parce qu'il ne parlait pas les
médecins de little rock rod spittle
l'avait pensé amnésique
parce qu'il avait dessiné un piano de
concert et jouer quelques notes
il avait été surnommé piano man et son
portrait avait fait le tour du monde
quatre mois de silence quatre mois de
suspense quatre mois des enquêtes pour
essayer d'identifier ce virtuose au
regard mélancolique il était reconnu
successivement finlandais italien voire
room aujourd'hui fin du mystère piano
man a donc parlé il est allemand
quand il a été trouvé par la police ils
étaient dans la détresse il avait perdu
son emploi et essayer de se suicider il
s'est dit homosexuel venant de bavière
et selon la presse britannique il aurait
même précisé que ces contacts
professionnels avec des malades mentaux
lui avait permis de simuler un
traumatisme
alors réelle détresse ou escroquerie
simulateur ouvrait dépressif les
psychiatres qui l'observaient garde à
leur tour le silence ce soir piano man a
quitté l'hôpital et il est reparti en
allemagne dans sa famille
polémique autour d'une innovation lancé
par google le moteur de recherche
américain sur internet pour se
distinguer de ses concurrents la firme
californienne a lancé un logiciel qui
permet de visualiser n'importe quel
endroit du monde
une intention ludique et commercial ni
qui commence à faire peur certaines
images de sites stratégiques pourrait
être détournée à des fins terroristes
patrice veulent et benoît faiveley
frédéric capron
voici la centrale nucléaire de lukla
ceds en australie dès qu'il a découvert
cette image sur le site google earth
l'un des responsables du programme
nucléaire australien a demandé qu on la
retire immédiatement
invoquant de possibles problèmes avec
des terroristes
car aujourd'hui sur certains sites
internet on peut voir ce qu avant on
nous cacher voici par exemple la tour
eiffel d'un côté c'est une image bien
innocente
de l'autre elle est si précise qu'elle
pourrait servir à quelques personnes
malintentionnées pour préparer un
attentat que ce soit le palais de
l'elysée l'aéroport de roissy charles de
gaulle
le centre de londres la place saint
pierre à rome le siège de la cia à
langley ou la maison blanche à
washington
plus personne n'est à l'abri toutes ces
images sont maintenant dans le domaine
public et cette situation inquiète les
experts ya des dangers éventuellement
mais le problème c'est que l'imagerie
n'est pas la seule chose informations
donc certes on pourra récupérer une
image on pourra avoir un certain nombre
d'informations
mais ce sera pas forcément suffisant des
dizaines de satellites civils et
militaires surveillent chaque seconde
notre planète
pour le moment les images les plus
précises ne sont pas disponibles
elles sont soigneusement gardés par les
services secrets des pays concernés
mais pour combien de temps qui aurait
pensé que cette image parfaite de la
centrale du bugey dans l'ain serait un
jour disponible sur internet et que sur
ce cliché de la place rouge à moscou
on pourrait compter les voitures garées
sur le parking
explication patrice pelé après un mois
de juillet très morose à fréquentation
touristique en france a retrouvé des
couleurs mois d'août pour l'instant les
professionnels n'ont pas chiffré les
retombées économiques
mais les grandes tendances montrent que
le sud et paris s'en sortent bien
contrairement au littoral breton céline
crespy eric de l'agneau facile 15 août
hôteliers restaurateurs commence à
compter les fonds de caisse dans ce
camping
heureusement que le mois d'août a permis
de faire le plein la première quinzaine
de juillet a été très difficile et une
fois qu'on est complet on est complet
donc c'est vrai que j'ai peut-être vu un
peu plus de monde qu'au mois de juillet
mais bon ce qui est perdu est perdu
économe les français le nombre de nuits
à l'hôtel ou au camping a baissé de 4%
cette année pire pour les locations
meublées en chute de 10% en fait 65 %
des vacanciers se débrouille pour ne pas
payer de logements pendant leurs
vacances
les étés dans la famille ou chez les
amis ont crû de 2% principales régions
victimes la bretagne et la montagne le
sud sans faire mieux un bon millésime
2005 qu'on peut dire 2004 était beaucoup
moins bien seul et la présentation
ressemble à l'année 2003 quant à paris
et bien elle attire toujours autant un
incontournable pour les étrangers comme
dit le proverbe si tu ne viens pas à
paris ça signifie que tu n'es pas venu
en mieux
l'image de la capitale a même l'air de
s'être améliorée améliorations il ya
plus de cas katché sur le trottoir
attention en fait la destination france
souffre de la concurrence de nouveaux
eldorados la croatie par exemple a été
visité par deux fois plus de français
cette année que l'année dernière
aujourd'hui une dizaine de départements
a déjà demandé à être classé en calamité
agricole en raison de la sécheresse qui
affecte les cultures surtout dans
l'ouest de la france une réunion sur ce
sujet doit avoir lieu le 8 septembre
prochain
pour l'instant le manque d'eau n'affecte
pas trop les activités de loisirs
parfois il faut simplement s'adapter
c'est le cas des parcours de canyoning
dans les gorges du verdon nathalie
jourdan frédéric cerulli concentrer les
vacanciers c'est pas la peine de se
crisper regarder la courbe de loi
voulait contient des sels de
réhydratation lalive à juliette pour sa
première descente en rappel un pied
derrière l'autre suspendu à un harnais
c'est le lot des camionneurs mais
habituellement là ça aurait dû faire
plus le canyoning séquences totalement
une épreuve de haies 8 mai cette année
les cagnottes sont plus secs
le manque de pluie a obligé les guides à
modifier leur parcours les perd un peu
en esthétique par contre me gagne en
sécurité parce que c'est pas l'unsa
et en plus ici c'est une partie qui
rejoint une autre partie qui est
beaucoup plus aquatique donc dans ce
cadre là c'est pas gênant il ya
effectivement d'autres canyon où on ne
va plus parce que parce qu'il ya pas
d'eau ce canyon main c'est donc un peu
exception y a pas de quoi se noyer mais
la combinaison est tout de même
recommandé pour le passage sous la
douche et bancs tout le monde
on retrouve le sourire jusqu'au deuxième
souffle la cible plus basse et légumes
trop d'élan et c'est là par l'unc ont
apprécié
le vix sportif est gratifiant l'obstacle
franchie on a vite fait de se prendre
pour des aventuriers de l'extrême par
les chargeurs dément
on évitera bien simple en est ce que
c'est une bonne chose parce qu'on voit
sa vie tragique accident
et puis pour paris si on applique ce
musellement réforme passe bien - 0 hic
plus nombreux les petits sous idéal pour
dégonfler les goûts par endroits
l'activité autorise même le barbotage vu
le manque d'eau c'est plutôt de saison
football match nul entre le paris
saint-germain et 3 1 partout hier soir
lors de la 4e journée de ligue 1 buts de
pauleta pour le psg en première mi temps
dès la reprise sébastien d'aller égalise
pour 3 le thésée reste premier du
classement à la différence de buts
devant lyon et puis pour sa dernière
course sur une piste britannique dame
keylios anobli après son doublé
olympique à athènes sur 800 et 1500 m a
eu le droit à tous les honneurs malgré
sa huitième place
arrivé en hélicoptère elle a ensuite
sorti ses deux médailles d'or pour
monter sur un podium
sous une pluie de confettis aux couleurs
sur britannique
ils sont sexagénaires et milliardaires
les rolling stones viennent d'entamer à
boston une nouvelle tournée mondiale la
31e depuis le début de leur carrière
meetic
le groupe n'a rien perdu de son énergie
et continue enthousiasmé le public les
trente six mille billets sont partis en
vue d'une journée élise chassaing
à chaque fois on croit que c'est la
dernière
mais finalement rien n'arrête les
rolling stones ce et certainement pas
les 60 de bougies que vient de souffler
mick jagger
35 dates prévues rien que sur le
continent américain
il ya des stones sont enchaîné les
morceaux de leur prochain album
bigger bang et les vieux tubes
le public ils ont un peu hésitant au
début les niveaux niveaux chance en mai
après six mois ça s'abîme
mais dommage pour la polémique
les vétérans du rock n'ont pas joué le
titre dont tout le monde parle sweet ni
ophone critiques acerbes de george bush
pour l'entendre en live il faudra
peut-être attendre la suite de la
tournée qui passera en france l'été
prochain
mais déjà une chose est sûre une tournée
des stones ce est toujours monumentale
il y a deux ans trois millions quatre
cent mille personnes les avait vus sur
scène et cela avait rapporté 300
millions de dollars
et on termine par l'image de la
passation de pouvoir entre marc tessier
patrick de carolis qui a pris
officiellement aujourd'hui la présidence
de france télévisions élu pour cinq ans
par le csa le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel patrick de carolis a
annoncé la nomination de catherine
duhamel comme directeur général chargé
des antennes du groupe et de thierry
bert comme directeur général chargé de
la gestion notamment les finances et de
l'audit de france télévisions voilà
c'est la fin de ce journal merci à vous
de m'avoir suivi tout de suite la météo
de patrice drevet 20h55 troisième partie
de votre saga estivale trois femmes
un soir d'été à 00h15 le journal de la
nuit vous sera présentée par jean claude
renaud et on se quitte sur cette image
de joutes nautiques c'est une tradition
datant de 1666 dans le port de sète où
chaque année de juin à septembre
un véritable championnat est organisé
entre les différents ports de la région
les jouteurs trophées chacun sur un
bateau cherche à l'aide d'une lance en
bois à faire tomber bien sûr
l'adversaire dans l'eau excellente
soirée souffrance veut à demain à 20
heures